bon après j'ai com j'ai essayé à faire
un petit peu la Manche ça marchait pas
Dubut très fort bon par c'était pas
facile les gens ont peur parce qu'il te
voient ils ont peur que tu prendes leur
portefeuille tout ça pas un France s'il
vous
[Musique]
plaît
la plupart d'entre eux se réfugient dans
le métro parce qu'il y fait chaud monde
hors de la surface de la lumière et du
temps piège à force certains risquent
d'y rester
tu as quel âge toi 3
an je plus pas rester comme
ça il faut que jeit
is ça fait combien de temps que vous
vivez dans le métro 1 an et demi je je
arrivé à Paris avec un PUL l'argent je
do MRE en hôtel qu en chour après fini
avec
l'argent comme ça là je sais pas
qu'est-ce que je fais
maintenant je je
promenais sur la rue je vois le gens qui
fait la
manche comme comme je vois ça je dis
pourquoi tu fais pas ça personne qui qui
me connaît normalement je fais
pasmalement dans ma ville il m'a connaît
les gens c'est une honte j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un qui fait aussi la
Manche et je demandé lui où
tu il m'a dit
il c'est la première fois dans votre vie
que vous vivez comme ça oui c'est la
première fois qu'est-ce que vous faisiez
avant je travaill 15
années sur le ousine de faire et avant
avant je
travaille
chantier je travaille aussi dans la
forêt avec 18 ans j'ai été à la Légion
étranger vous pensez à votre vie avant
ah oui c'est dur c'est c'est c'est une
grande différence si vous dormez dans
une
lit vous avez pas de flotte vous avez
rien
je veux pas continue comme
ça j'ai 20 temps ça fait combien de
temps que tu vis ici dans le métro ça
fait bon ça fait à peu près 5 ans tu es
arrivé là comment je suis arrivée bon
c'est que pour mes parents j'ai eu des
problèmes avec mes parents ça fait que
j'ai commencé à galérer un petit peu ici
ça m'a donné envie bon et puis et ça ça
a été plus loin je dire j'ai eu envie de
connaître un petit peu l'ambiance bon
j'ai commencé à voir l'ambiance j'ai
fait commencé à faire des conneries ça
fait que bon ma mère m'a mis dehors
après au début c'était très difficile
parce que c'est dur c'est puisant c'est
la rue c'est pas jolie on peut s'en
sortir c'est c'est magnifique bon bon
après j'ai com j'ai essayé à faire un
petit peu la Manche ça marchait pas au
début très fort bon par cétait pas
facile les gens ont peur parce qu'ils te
voient ils ont peur que tu prendes leur
portefeuille tout ça en France s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
merci autrefois installé dans les issues
de secours du Forum des h Sandra a
aujourd'hui du mal à trouver un abri la
direction fermer les portes trop de
violence trop de
drogue dis-moi la drogue tu connais ou
pas oui ça va moi ce que je prends c'est
des cachets que je prenais des cachets
et bon je fumer mais comment on dit dans
la vie si on a de la volonté on s'en
sort et ben j'ai réussi à m'en sortir tu
arrêé j'ai arrêté ça fait pas longtemps
ça fait 5 jours que je tiens le
coup souvent j'en vois qui prenent si
j'ai envie mais je me suis dit dans ma
tête si c'est pour mon enfant qui que je
porte et c'est pour ma santé aussi
enceinte de 4 mois Sandra a rendez-vous
ce jour-là avec une assistante sociale
un bureau à la station Strasbourg sanis
au cœur du métro l'association Coup de
pousce
bonjour Alors comment ça va depuis
l'autre jour ça va doucement doucement
ou qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors de
nouveau
ach ça va je fais un peu Laam j'essaie
de m'en
sortir installé sur le réseau par la
RATP et la délégation générale de lutte
contre la drogue coup de pouce comprend
trois assistants sociaux se
éducateurs depuis mars 91 il travaille à
la réinsertion des marginaux du sous-sol
arpentant les couloirs à la recherche de
contact avec ceux qu'ils appellent leurs
clients
bonjour je m'appelle Franky je suis
éducateur j'ai les gens qui sont en
difficulté dans le métro je voulais
savoir si vous aviez besoin de quelque
chose ça faire la G du
Nord toi franchement j'en Mar et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé un peu au
départ bah c'està dire que bon moi j'ai
eu ma mère qui m'a fouté
dehors ma mère mon père il m' foutu
dehors il a fall que je débrouille
qu'est-ce qu'il vont donner tu et je
m'aperçois que plus j'essaient de m'en
sortir moi j'arrive comment ça
va ça va ça va bien bon pr rien nou on
est obligé d'essayer de faire un pe
manche pour on g pas beaucoup par jour
mais on est heureux on rigole il nous
faut la
tranquillité bonjour ah ça va je vouis
savoir si vous auriez besoin de quelque
chose parce que nous on propose du
travail des hébergements et moi je veux
plus travailler moi je vous ah bon
travailler je veux plus d'accord je suis
plus un descl ok parce que nous ce qu'on
peut proposer aussi d'aider les gens au
niveau de de refire faire des papiers et
cetera non non il y a rien qui
m'intéresse il y a des échecs enfin il y
a des gens qui refusent qui vous savez
d'où ça vient ça ouais parce que c'est
pas le moment pour eux ils ont pas envie
ou par peur aussi de recommencer dans la
société les gens ont peur de ça oui
beaucoup ou
pourquoi quand ça fait de 3 ans voire 10
ans qu'on a complètement quitté la
réalité de du monde extérieur on a du
mal à s'insérer à recommencer une
démarche
quoi
tableau je su en train de
faire c'est un tableau qui qui décrit
plus ou moins ce que je vis quoi
la zone quoi mais bon avec des moments
de bonheur des moments d'angoisse parce
que la zone c'est pas complètement noir
quoi tu combien depuis combien de temps
làdedans ça fait je sa
pas 8 ans tu es arrivé là comment
bah c'est c'est un choix
quoi c'est un choix bon je que vu que je
n'ai aucun
diplôme se seul av
venir j'aurais pu avoir c'est B
caricature quoi mais bon c'est
travailler en usine ou être
manœuvre bon moi tout c'était pas mon
intentioni je préfère vivre dehors au
moins je suis libre
en fait ils n'ont jamais choisi qui
choisirait une vie comme ça autrement
que quelqu'un qui présenter une
pathologie mentale on peut pas choisir
cette VI il ne l'ont jamais
choisi conséquence de l'rance
souterraine les désordres psychiques
sont nombreux chez les honneurs du métro
maladie mentale pour 20 à 30 % d'entre
eux dépression nerveuse ou bien
faabulation et mythomanie pour une
grande
majorité sinvente toujours des histoires
c'est une c'est protecteur une façon de
se défendre contre contre la réalité
alors bon on invente des des situations
mobolant on s'invente un passé reluisant
à présent qui au fond n'est pas si
mauvais que ça et un futur très très
positif on en sait qu'il n'en est rien
tu peux me raconter à quelle époque tu
es arrivé dans le métro dans les années
80 pourquoi tu pourquoi tu es arrivé là
j'avais fait une de chez moi et
donc j'avais galéré un peu je me suis
retrouvé ici à Châtelet
quoi on s'amusait bien on rigolait on
partait on on allait de ville en ville
c'était bien quoi on pouvit CER entre
nous quoi on sentait vraiment qu'il y
avait comment dire ouais ouais qu'il y
avait un rapprochement quoi il y avait
des bandes oui des bandes ouais on séit
tous entre nous
quoice que tu fais maintenant je fais
maintenant et ben j'essaie de m'en
sortir petit à petit c'est-à-dire je
cherche du boulot je fais pas mal de
stages je sage la cuisine agent de
sécurité je pas mal de trucs tu vis où
maintenant je vis chez mes parents il
fallait que j'ai un endroit pour vivre
pour parce queil vont rester dehors
c'est c'est bien beau tu vois de galérer
mais il faut avoir un endroit se laver
pour être propre vis-à-vis des
gens quand on est dans la rue on attrape
n'importe quoi si on n pas toujours nos
produits nosè tout ça c'est sûr qu' on
se lave pas rien va attraper des pou des
et bonattraper c'est une maladiie
comment tu vis là en ce moment le le
fait d'attendre un bébé alors que tu vis
dans la Gère c'est très dur c'est déjà
c'est très dur une meuf une femme quand
elle est enceinte c'est très dur mais il
faut se ti dans la vie c'est foncé je
fonce et bon je j'essaie de m'en sortir
et que je me dis dans ma tête il faut
que j'ai le plus possible d'hgène et
j'ai le plus d'gn je lave mes affaires
je fais mon petit business comme
toujours matin laver laver mes affaires
je sens pas mauvais je suis propre
voilà vous arrivez à dormir toutes les
nuits
correctement 3 qu jours pas 3 qu jours
que vous n'avez pas dormi
ouais et vous faites quoi pendant ces
nuits alors ah on fait quoi c'est mal d'
c'est froid ça pleut c'est obligé pour
mancher hein si vous restez sur la place
vous avez
froid
où je veux aller
maintenant à c'est fermé dans la nuit le
métro c'est fermé où vous
VZ ça la flotte c'est impossible
pour
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est possible d'avoir des
amis dans le métro am moi je suis une
HME jeche toujours tout
c'est mieux c'est pas t camarad parce
que il commence à boire il se lav pas il
se rass pas ça je veux pas je veux pas
marcher avec
eux agression des plus fréquentes entre
zonard le vol surtout celui des papiers
d'identité Dr RAR et monayable dès sa
première nuit dans le métro Paul s'est
tout fait
dérober avec l'aide de pous rencontré
quelques jours auparavant il entreprend
de récupérer passeport travail logement
lundi oui c'est Suel et on ira ensemble
tous les deux pour rejoindre ce monsieur
oui on fait comme ça bon il y a il y a
l'hôtel pour ce soir voilà l'hôtel pour
ce soir et la Villette à partir de
demain 13h oui pour 15
jours la ville dans la rue dans le métro
et permanence une vie de protection il
faut se protéger contre tout et d'abord
contre sa solitude et contre soi-même
contre sa propre
[Musique]
réalité protection ou fuite plus de 65 %
des marginaux du sous-sol sont en état
de dépendance vis-à-vis d'une ou
plusieurs substances alcool
tranquillisant ou
drogue
il y a des gens illustres qui sont
drogués Rimo CCTO bikovski c'est un
choix que tu as fait
toi non bon moi ouais moi ouais j'aime
ça
quoi mais pas toujours il il y a des
moments où j'ai une blouse j'ai j'ai
besoin d'un complice quoi et ce complice
céit c'est métamorphosé sous sous cette
forme là
quoi le le plus dur en fait c'est c'est
que je me
sens à la fois libre et enfermé quoi je
suis je suis libre du fait que je je ne
dépends de personne j'ai d j'ai d à
recevoir de personne quoi mais je suis
je suis enfermé parce que j'ai
l'impression de ne pas avancer quoi par
je je pense avoir potentiel comme comme
comme chacun quoi bon et moi j'
j'aimerais bien pouvoir juste justement
m'exprimer dans la peinture mais
m'exprimer à fond
quoi petit boulot incertains stage
aléatoire Daniel prétend s'être
définitivement sorti de la zone chaque
jour ou presque il est là au milieu de
ses anciens compagnons des Rance mais
pourquoi tu tu reviens toujours dans cet
endroit c'est difficile de couper le
cordon B c'est difficile non ah ouais
ouais ouais ouais pourquoi c'est
difficile parce que c'est un coin où je
sais pas un coin où tu arrives où tu es
jeunes tu as tu as 16 ans tu
sais c'est presce que c'est la moitié de
ta vie un peu je sais pas c'est même
c'est pas la moitié de ta vie mais quand
même c'est un peu ça fait partie de ta
vie parce que tu as galéré ici tu as
grandi tu connais le quartier tu as
envie d'y retourner parce que tu tu as
envie de savoir qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que ça change est-ce que il y
a les mêmes têtes tout se passe un peu
comme comme s'il s'agissait d'une
maladie qui une fois guérie se
remanifeste malgré tout un peu de temps
en temps et finalement on y revient pas
parce qu'on y est bien et parce que il y
a une sorte de
d'attirance difficile à exprimer mais
vers un milieu dans lequel finalement on
était mal et c'est peut-être aussi une
façon d'exprimer que enfin on s'en est
sorti alors on peut aller voir les
copains sous le prétexte en tout cas de
leur montrer qu'on s'en est sorti mais
peut-être pour retrouver un petit peu et
se désintoxiquer si je puis dire assez
lentement
de de cette vie de cette vie passée et
pas aussi parce que la vie extérieure
est pas forcément
simple on eSport c'est russir dans la
vie avoir un travail créer avenir et
après faire un commerce je sais pas je
suis pas encore là je peux pas vous dire
tant qu'il est pas né je peux pas savoir
mon avenir comment il va être je peux
pas juger du jour au lendemain parce que
du jour lendemain je peux m'en sor et
retomber je ne sais pas tu sais si c'est
une fille ou un garçon tu je ne sais pas
encore qu'est-ce que tu voudrais moi je
préféris qu'il a un garçon bon une fille
souvent elle peut devenir comme moi dans
la rue avoir envie de connaître des gens
bon on en av marre d'avoir une vie
normale et bon il se sauve et puis qu'à
la fin il se trouve comme moi qu'est-ce
que tu lui diras à ta fille pour pas
qu'elle devienne comme comme tu es là en
ce moment ben j'expliquerai la vie déjà
j'expliquerai tout ce que comment ça
s'est passé pour éviter de faire les
conneries tout ça et puis voilà c'est
elle a choisir si elle voudra vivre dans
la rue elle fera ce qu'elle voudra elle
a droit d'avoir des amis je l'empêcherai
pas mais la drogue question de drogue et
tout ça c'est négatif ce que je veux
c'est qu'elle réussi à avir un avenir
comme moi j'ai pu avoir et j'ai pas
voulu
[Musique]